yeah he went welcome to this video
playing international indian king then
venkatachala saravanan oh my god that
was almost certainly wrong so yeah
Scudder oh this line oh my god has been
ages since I looked dad everything g3 is
right pool I had it on the board once
against the an IM lowering that cost
down long time ago though i think
something like this is right but well
we'd see we'll see what the Indian King
is up to I always sometime I said have a
healthy suspicion healthy suspicion is
that a word is that an expression yeah
I'm always skeptical about bishop a five
lines I always feel that they are very
unnatural but some are well established
theory if in the news oh there is one
line that is really having a main line a
complete main line status nowadays
ok so if he goes 94 I would always have
before takes takes before us may be
possible and because that was hanging
interesting yeah it's a bit of an
irritating position type I wonder if
it's actually interesting indisposition
trying to fly very strange position
maybe it takes place each fight himself
just have to say I have to accelerate a
little bit you know I don't get get this
get this going yet is interesting now
and I should have thought about it for a
moment more because this is this is
allowing the double porn isn't all that
unusual here it's just a very bad
version here I should have thought about
this a little bit more no black is fine
sometimes you can allow the devil porn
and then play for like night f1e 3d five
it was my idea but it's a terrible
version it's a very terrible version
really hate to be in this position at
night everyone ok i cannot cannot allow
h4 probably and it is probably losing
with best play remarkable I think
businesses I don't know if this is
helping him a lot he has weakened his
position also a little bit it might
still be good for black but I am feel
like I wasn't much more much more
difficult to perform right so it's so
bad it's so pretty bad
I should probably make a draw but I'd
never like to do that I will be fired
huh this could be five okay um anyway if
I unpinned us this is still quite
interesting because he either has to
weaken his pawn structure here step dad
for me and it's actually not so bad okay
i can check here and take me five and
also i mean taking can also take it take
on c5 it's also not bad that's nothing
wrong with that i believe we should be
for 23 years nothing special if I'm
worried what to take
yeah so
check
black resin yeah i outplayed me irony
that was a very bad position neither the
diskette decisions that I took their how
hard played this year was really
dreadful yeah and I don't know maybe
here I actually had something and was
taking because after this there is
before I only saw that after he played
we should be seven but then that the
opportunity was already gone and he
definitely does not want to do this Sam
strategically that's bad but I can even
do this again now this is a problem so
that was an opportunity that I missed I
can switch it on yeah and then here i
meanyeah black is fine absolutely fine
before was a bad idea actually when i
played this I had this idea to provoke
this double pong position but that
really was pretty bad I mean I'm just in
a terrible position here you know this
is not so bad if you have like it for
extra moose yeah i just want to show you
the idea i mean it doesn't work but this
is what I played just a general idea I
know the difference c4 is hanging with
the idea is to do to get something to
get something like that where this pawn
is those pawns are not so bad because
they cover deform but I never get there
you never get them and in my position is
just terrible i am yeah i mean this is
this is certainly fine how it did it and
now this is just a question of being
accurate the could enter the ID of crew
g6 to play f6 and queen jf seven looks
very nice next time is very bad i mean i
think this is also not a bad idea
but that's already heavily criticized if
you want by the engine Bishop g-form man
that's also very good notes I have to
take and now I get to look these three
and clean age 60 God's mighty you can
play Ellicott's ganya queen is a group
t3 whoopty 628 back that's a nightmare
position really nightmare NTN somewhat
continuing with a bit too bit cheeky
took two to not make the drawers okay I
wanted to risk it and that's really a
mistake it looks strong but after this
I'm back in the game absolutely H form I
could take an h 5 even better ka7 a bit
surprised that the engine evaluates the
position as completely equal you would
and I was thinking at least I should be
able to get some kind of ending up on up
that I might not be able to win but
should be more than 0.3 yeah I tried
this and it this is not easy for black
top science this is immediately losing
but it sounds yeah I'm a little bit
better here at least okay would have
been tricky were 30 seconds but okay no
risk no fun thanks for watching